[Music]
foreign
this is just a typical morning of eating
some cereal with lactose free milk as I
watched some videos on the internet
using closed captioning while looking up
directions to my MRI appointment okay
maybe not really typical but just about
everything here the milk the TV the
graphics cards the internet the closed
captioning the GPS the MRI machine were
made possible because of government
Investments it's probably the case that
every technology used today at some
point there was like Government funding
involved in the latest technology that
the US government is getting involved in
is manufacturing microchips folks we
need to make these chips here in America
President Biden just signed a bill into
law today boosting domestic
semiconductor production there are some
big companies that are set to benefit if
it's a good idea to make the
semiconductors here why do we need the
government to help us here's why the US
government is giving private companies
billions of dollars and why many
economists are calling the chips act a
return to Industrial policy
industrial policy is actually quite a
simple term it's a set of policies that
try to affect the outcome of some
particular industry or Industries
industrial policy can be done through
things like tariffs that make us-made
products cheaper than foreign ones or
through tax incentives like getting
money back if you put solar panels on
your house or what has been less popular
in recent years direct Investments
let's go back way back to Alexander
Hamilton in 1790 Hamilton proposed
tariffs on imported goods in order to
encourage his fellow countrymen to buy
more American Products this is the
immense plant which gave birth to the
atomic bomb and brought the world to a
new Crossroad fast forward to the 20th
century to prevent the spread of
radioactive contaminants used during the
Manhattan Project the U.S government
funded the development of the HEPA
filter which is used in many air
purifiers sold today World War II also
required enormous investment in radio
technology shipbuilding and jet engines
the defense department was largely the
main buyer of many of these Technologies
the commercial Market was quite small
the defense Market was quite big and so
they could really drive a lot of the
movement in industry in the 1960s the US
government spent more money on research
and development than all other
governments All Foreign private
companies and all U.S private companies
combined why the Cold War and the Space
Race what did the Space Program give us
it gave us Tang from Gemini to the
shuttle to Earth's families great
mornings have taken off with tang yeah
it gave us Tang but it also gave a
gazillion other things it wasn't talked
about as industrial policies talked
about his space policy or defense policy
or health policy but it was a de facto
industrial policy and liftoff a de facto
industrial policy with many unforeseen
benefits this robotic prosthetic leg is
powered by small powerful Motors
originally designed for a robotic arm on
the International Space Station
like many of these Technologies
semiconductors originated from research
and development programs funded by the
U.S taxpayer the birth of semiconductors
in the United States had a lot to do
with the fact that the Department of
Defense and the Space Program were the
first big early customers for
semiconductors
since 2006 China has prioritized
catching up to the West technologically
but doing that requires semiconductors
China has ramped up its investment in
ships Senator Mark Warner who is the
chairman of the Senate select committee
on intelligence has long been warning
about the growing threat posed by China
China has been able to throw literally
you know two three four times as much
money at trying to build up their
semiconductor chip capacity as the
United States this is where the chips
act comes in the legislation offers 53
billion dollars in direct investment
plus a separate tax incentive program to
reinvigorate the U.S chip industry so
what the chip spill did was say we're
going to take 52 billion dollars but
we're going to take about 40 billion of
that and try to get the semiconductor
factories that are called Fabs get the
Fabs to locate here in America today the
U.S still dominates the most lucrative
links in the semiconductor supply chain
including the design of chips but the
fabrication of chips has increasingly
moved to China South Korea and Taiwan
over the last 20 years a lot of that
industry has migrated to East Asia where
land and labor are cheaper and there are
a lot of subsidies available because of
this the US share of global chip making
has shrunk from 37 in 1990 to 12 in
2020. China went from zero to about 15
percent in the same time
if we don't do this
I don't think there'll be another chip
manufacturing facility built in America
Senator Warner sees this as a national
security issue over the last
particularly 15 or 20 years what we've
seen is that National Security is no
longer who has the most military
hardware but also who controls what
technology domains the US now buys more
than 90 percent of its Advanced chips
from Taiwan an island China sees as its
territory any conflict in Taiwan could
dramatically disrupt Global chip
supplies we all saw what happened during
the pandemic when chip factories shut
down overseas we can never let that
happen again we have never before been
in this kind of a cold war type conflict
with a power that was also a worthy
economic peer and I think it has
awakened in the United States an
awareness that we cannot simply allow
the private Market to allow vital
Technologies and capabilities to
entirely migrate to a country that we
are in an adversarial situation with so
our competitors are pouring tens of
billion dollars into boost their own
supply of these essential semiconductors
and the United States needs to keep up
and to compete
the vast majority of our colleagues
agreed that this was an important and
critical task when it was passed the
chips act received rare bipartisan
support the yays are 64 the Nays are 33.
there is Broad bipartisan agreement that
China is the challenge of our time and
that in these areas of Technology we
can't allow America to fall behind
critics of industrial policy accuse it
of picking winners rather than letting
the free market determine which
companies succeed some of the most
famous industrial policy failures
include investment targeted at a single
company at former president Donald
Trump's urging in 2017 taiwan's Foxconn
Technology Group promised to build a
flat panel display Factory in Wisconsin
this is a great day for American workers
and for everyone who believes in the
concept and the label made in the USA
But five years later and that factory
remains unbuilt critics of industrial
policy also to solyndra when it's
completed in a few months the lender
expects to hire a thousand workers to
manufacture solar panels and sell them
Across America and around the world
but in 2011 the solar manufacturer went
bankrupt after it defaulted on 535
million dollars in Federal loans
but proponents of the chips act say it's
not about picking specific firms like
Intel or Taiwan semiconductor good
industrial policy funds a variety of
firms big small even foreign long as
they're doing the work in the U.S and
they're not our adversaries
the ability to apply for this money is
drawing major investment from these
firms right now both Intel and tsmc are
spending billions to build new Fabs in
the U.S I think one thing we're going to
learn is that industrial policy is
expensive
and we have large government deficits
and so I think one of the things that
will put the brakes on the rush to
Industrial policy is the fact that
you'll have to persuade you know
Congress to vote for this money and
that's not easy to do the Republican
Senators for example who gave their
support to the chips act they did so
because they saw this as a narrow
exception to their General mistrust of
the government being able to spend money
better than the free market and I think
that there will not be many other
industries that meet that test
yeah
foreign
[Music]